Uh, okay.
Let's see if we can squeeze another call in.
Let's go to the two one zero area code.
Who's calling today from two one zero which
is a dangerous area code.
We've got a lot of trolls in San Antonio.
Hello?
Yeah.
Hey,
what's up David?
Good to talk to you.
If you already been asked about this, I know
you did a video and a bunch of comments were
like kind of freaking out on you, but I just
wanted to get clarification on why you think
Andrew Yang is anti-union.
I mean, you put a video up and then he literally
said, I love union.
Yeah, I miss heard it and I made a correction
the week a completely misheard it, so I gave
it
cool.
I was freaking out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I just, I thought he said I'm not a big
fan of unions and he said I'm a big fan of
unions and I just misheard it.
Okay, cool.
That makes me feel so like direction.
I was like, dude, this is, he's always so
on point and then he just blatantly, okay,
great.
And then one last thing about you hanging,
I was wondering if you could explain a little
bit of the big differences and problems you
have between the Medicare for all and the
buy an option.
Just talking about like the singer pay Pale
paired like all the way through or the buyin
it.
I don't really understand that.
I tried to look into it
with peace and love you.
You're a bit confused about Medicare, medicare
buy in single payer.
We're going to lay out all of the options
soon.
It's sort of exceeds the scope of what I have
time for right now, but my, my thing is you
shouldn't be choosing whether to pay for Medicare.
It should just, either everybody has access
because of the taxes that they pay or they
don't.
But the buy in part I, I'm against and we'll
talk more about it in an upcoming segment.
Yeah.
Awesome.
I'm really glad to hear that that was corrected
and yeah, looking forward to more stuff to
me.
I really appreciate it, David.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate the call that does it for today.
Sorry everybody I couldn't get to, but we
will take calls again maybe on an upcoming
lives.